what's the deal with this Sheen thing
because I saw a couple things about this
Sheen is like a skincare brand I think
and they did like an influencer trip
where they like went to the clothing
brand oh I don't know if you're
confusing with tart Cody oh sure I don't
know
well you're confusing it with tart
stupid yeah sorry you know the
difference between Sheen and tart fast
fashion okay so which is like the devil
right everyone thinks that fast fashion
is like the worst thing ever like it's
bad for the climate and it all is also
like bad for employees right yeah
because they make everything in like
factories and I think that's the what
happened here is that they like did an
influence their trip to one of their
factories an influencer is under Fire
for offering a glowing review of a Sheen
Factory during a sponsored trip despite
the company's long history of Labor
abuses
so they're going public so it's kind of
like a propaganda like marketing scheme
to have her talk about how good it is
it's a psyop we just pulled up my mouth
I'm still picking it up off the ground
it's so big today we are I am so
impressed it is so big I literally can't
pick my job off the ground yeah [__]
hella kids on there yeah yeah
so many adorable children too many to
count I didn't realize you could start
working so young yeah you had to pass
these bills in America that was for
children to work earlier yeah most
fascinating thing is that I've seen the
exact process of she and clothing I've
seen how it's designed I've seen How
It's Made I've now I'm going to see how
it's packaged and shipped off and I feel
like that's such a unique perspective to
be able to see at this is like when it's
like it's like touring Amazon facilities
and being like that's wonderful no this
is like when like North Korea like takes
people on a tour you know what I mean
and it's all like just like fake
manicured like yeah actors being like
yeah we totally have food
too much actually they have so much food
they have a thousand Indian kids hiding
in a [__] storage container and
they're like if one of you talks yeah
we're gonna put this in the ocean
great this is great Sheen was like oh
we're getting complaints about our labor
practices well we'll just have no one do
it yeah exactly oh we'll just buy a
bunch of Machinery to do it yeah
no see no we're not abusing anyone yeah
no the machines do it all yeah no
there's no one
I mean that's definitely what the brand
point was like yeah to communicate yeah
like
okay just make sure they know that no
one works in the factory anymore we it's
not we can't we aren't able to treat
them shitty we would there's no one to
abuse
and go home feeling reassured feeling
like she in working for Xi'an and being
a consumer of Xi'an and I feel
comfortable spreading that message to my
community and to my family and friends
laughs
they got duped they got duped that must
have been a big big check that check big
old check last thing about the sheen
propaganda brand trip this company
releases over 300 000 new designs a year
and these people genuinely believe their
pattern cutting items one by one so did
they just fake all that yeah
really what a lot of people believe is
that like this was just for show for the
trip our Channel 4 documentary had the
first undercover investigation into the
factories in China that make clothes for
Sheen which revealed how many laws were
being broken regarding the working
conditions of the people making the
clothes there's video evidence they
aren't rumors China trip has been one of
the most life-changing trips of my life
getting to see the whole process of she
and he's got someone's mother
yeah
I was really excited and impressed to
see the working conditions the next day
we headed to them oh my God yeah that's
definitely that was a that was a
highlight of green yeah moment there you
know verbatim and just say when reading
from the paper
because it's a big check we want to make
sure we get this one
specify the positive nature of the
working conditions but don't say
this other stuff because we can get sued
yeah
worked in the fabric cutting department
and you guys know me she's an
investigative journalist so I asked her
all of our questions and she answered
them honestly and authentically she was
very surprised at all the rumors that
had been spread in the U.S she told me
about her family her lifestyle her
commute her hours her last stop was to
the sheen warehouse this place was
massive it's about 84 acres and almost
fully run by technology and automation I
was really impressed by the oh dude this
is just straight
this is like the [__] uh at the
investor
phone call before going live yeah yeah
how are we doing on that influencer Mark
and we're gonna need to Ram that we need
to pump that [__] up we need people
thinking that Sheen is a is a safe we
need them to know it's a Safe Company
it's a great place to work it's it's
exactly
um everything it's not yeah you know
yeah inside the sheen machine inside the
machine that's what they should have did
dude
machine yeah
oh my gosh like Sheen machine what i s
what I seen in the sheen machine yeah
damn
[Laughter]
that's what they should have called it
yeah
she and her mood fiending
what Cody's just rapping now what I seen
in the sheen machine
Shia fiend you should try that one
tonight yeah yeah
that Chad and JT show after the after
the other one after I do the sub of the
Mist Joe yeah the missed one oh that'd
be crazy dude just it bombs and then I
go straight into it yeah so this article
about Sheen
what I've seen inside the scene
oh my God that's an awfully hot coffee
pot
we have no regard for the worker who was
found to be paid 4
000 on
approximately encouraged to work up to
18 hours per day dude
879 uh Australian dollars annually
annually
which is 18-hour days and they're
punished if they make one one mistake by
two-thirds of their wage okay so they're
encouraged to work up to given only one
day of leave each month and we're found
washing their hair during lunch breaks
due to their toxic working environment
Sheen claims to never violate labor laws
yet these working conditions are in
strict breach of Chinese labor law which
states that work weeks cannot cannot
exceed 40 hours
sixty percent of their suppliers
factories violated their code of conduct
with a further 12 in violation of their
Zero Tolerance violation policy and over
700 audits completed in 2021 14 of
factories were found to violate working
hours with another 27 violating fire and
emergency preparedness
that's good one out of every four
factories
with a bunch of [__] cloth and
garments yeah
is not safe if it goes on fire are the
clothes just like dirt cheap
really
oh [__] dude they make boohoo
that's like the the love Island oh yeah
yeah got my new line with boo man yeah
yeah anymore